[Musique]
de tous les régimes politiques qui ont
forgé la france le second empire de
napoléon iii à imprimer l'image
indélébile d'une légende noire dans
notre conscience collective
si nous n'avons gardé de lui que de
souvenirs du coup d'état du 2 décembre
1851 qui lui permis d'anéantir la
république pour établir un régime
autoritaire
il est derrière le masque de celui que
victor hugo se plaisait à surnommé
napoléon le petit un personnage
autrement plus complexe
napoléon iii est un personnage tout à
fait captivant et les îles et secret il
est parfois très mystérieux dont on ne
sait jamais exactement ce qu'il pense et
ton concert mais quelle décision il va
prendre était-il très intelligent
etait-il stupide ou avait-il une
originalité telle qu'on ne pouvait pas
le classer dans les catégories ordinaire
de la condition humaine héritier
présomptif du trône impérial il vécu en
exil dans le culte de son illustre aïeul
napoléon 1er fomentant plusieurs
conspiration afin de s'emparer du
pouvoir qui le pense et il lui revenait
de droit
adoubé par le suffrage universel il
devint le premier président de la
république française le 10 décembre 1848
dès lors se sentant doublement légitime
à la fois sur son nom et sur le vote des
français la marche vers l' empire
pouvait enfin commencer
[Musique]
si le second empire fut le temps des
somptueuses fêtes impériale des éminents
musiciens rossini berlioz offenbach des
grands écrivains george sand hugo balzac
michelet lamartine mairie mais il fut
aussi marquée par l'odeur du charbon de
la vapeur par le brouhaha des usines
sidérurgiques sneider des travaux
d'aménagement par le préfet haussmann
des foules des grands magasins et des
expositions universelles
la période est quand même celle de
l'explosion des découvertes des
inventions de l'industrie le chemin de
fer et puis tous les aménagements de
paris et dans le pays
un certain nombre de de progrès de
décisions empire français est le pays le
plus riche d'europe voire du monde même
à cette époque là parce que napoléon iii
a fait développer le chemin de fer a
fait à créer les industries on à
l'éclairage au gaz on a inventé la
machine à coudre enfin la france est un
pays dans lesquels il fait certainement
bon vivre après l'angleterre la france
entrait dans une nouvelle ère une
croissance économique sans précédent la
révolution industrielle
pourtant en 1870 elle s'engagea dans une
guerre désastreuse face à la prusse qui
provoqua la chute de napoléon iii et du
second empire
tous
vous
louis napoléon bonaparte voit le jour
rue cerutti à paris le 20 avril 1808
accueilli par les honneurs militaires
des salves d'artillerie qui résonne dans
tout l'empiré
il est le fils cadet d'hortense de
beauharnais fille de l'impératrice
joséphine et de louis bonaparte roi de
hollande
ce qui fait de lui le neveu de
l'empereur napoléon 1er effectivement il
avait un lien du sang sauf à considérer
que hortense de beauharnais fille de
joséphine de beauharnais sa mère ait
fauté avec quelques personnes autres que
son mari alors ce n'est pas pour faire
état simples ragots que l'on dit ça
c'est une véritable hypothèse historique
il ya été très souvent question de la
bâtardise de louis napoléon le 4
novembre 1810 la cour impériale se
pressent à la chapelle du château de
fontainebleau où louis napoléon reçoit
le sacrement du baptême
deux ans plus tard napoléon 1er est à
l'apogée de sa gloire il domine toutes
les nations d'europe et règne sur près
de 40 millions de sujets son empire est
immense à l'égal de celui de césar ou
d'alexandre le grand
mais la dramatique campagne de russie
géant insaisissable des cimes sa grande
armée la campagne de france qui l'oppose
à une coalition anti française forte de
près d'un million d'hommes apporte elle
aussi son lot de morts et de
désillusions vers la perte de l'an pire
un premier exil contraint l'empereur a
laissé la france aux mains de louis
xviii frère de louis saez pour ne plus
régner que sur un royaume ridicule l'île
d'elbe la dynastie des bourbons est donc
rétablie mais la période dite des
cent-jours fois le retour en force de
l'aigle un second souffle de l'épopée
napoléonienne qui s'achève avec la
dramatique défaite de waterloo
elle conduit l'empereur vers son dernier
exil à sainte hélène
quand napoléon 1er son tonton était
parti pour la dernière campagne pour ce
qui serait la dernière campagne la
bataille de waterloo
il avait pris le pli louis napoléon qui
était un tout petit bonhomme un petit
bambin sur ses genoux il avait embrassé
en lui disant toi tu seras sans doute
l'avenir de la race
la loi du 2 janvier 1816 qui bannit la
famille bonaparte de france oblige la
mère de louis napoléon à céder ses biens
l'ex reine hortense de hollande s'exile
alors en suisse avec son fils au château
d'ars under the gun louis bonaparte son
époux part vivre à rome avec leur fils
aîné louis napoléon vite une enfance
idyllique passant son temps au bord du
lac de constance à parcourir la campagne
mais sa mère se soucient peu de son
éducation
si bien que louis bonaparte la menace de
lui retirer la garde quand il s'aperçoit
du faible niveau d'instruction de son
fils de 12 ans philippe leuba helléniste
fils d'un proche de robespierre devient
alors le précepteur du jeune garçon qui
le rejoint à augsburg dans le culte de
napoléon 1er
un ancien officier de l'anp pire lui
enseigne l'art de la guerre
[Musique]
le 5 mai 1821 napoléon 1er c'est un sur
l'île de sainte hélène à partir de 1823
louis napoléon fait un séjour à rome où
il découvre la politique aux côtés des
libéraux aux italiens le 16 septembre
1824 louis xviii meurt à son tour son
frère charles 10 monte sur le trône de
france et se fait sacrer à reims
renouant avec la tradition de l'ancien
régime les mouvements de contestation
gronde leroy tente de passer en force et
dissous la chambre des députés en
promulguant les ordonnances de saint
claud mais à la surprise générale une
majorité parlementaire libéral remporte
les élections et s'opposent bientôt
souverain les 27 28 et 29 juillet 1830
une nouvelle révolution se déclenche le
peuple parisien se soulèvent dressent
des barricades et affronte sans peur
l'armé du maréchal mme armand ce bain de
sang des trois glorieuses renverse
brutalement charles otis ainsi la
monarchie de juillet arborent le drapeau
tricolore et la maison d'orléans france
cadette des bourbons accès de pouvoir
intronisant louis-philippe roi des
français le 9 août 1830
dans l'esprit de louis napoléon qui
embrasse une carrière militaire en
suisse germe l'espoir d'un retour
triomphal des bonaparte mais la nouvelle
assemblée orléaniste vote une loi
confirmant l'interdiction de séjour de
l'ex famille impériale en france louis
napoléon et son frère aîné napoléon
louis s'impliquent tu as rome aux côtés
des républicains l'italien qui souhaite
unifier le royaume est dépossédé le pape
de son pouvoir
ils combattent vaillamment l'armée
autrichienne venus secourir le pape
quand napoléon louis succombe à une
épidémie de rougeole
après la mort de son frère aîné napoléon
louis en 1831 et du duc de reichstadt
napoléon 2 le 22 juillet 1830 de louis
napoléon apparaît comme l'héritier
présomptif de la couronne impériale
il croit en son étoile et s'emploie à
organiser son retour avec les chefs de
file de l'opposition en france
parallèlement il continue sa carrière
militaire en suisse dont il obtient la
nationalité la publication d'un manuel
d'artillerie lui vaut même une promotion
au grade de capitaine
le 30 octobre 1836 louis napoléon
tentent de soulever strasbourg avec une
poignée de partisans
ils espèrent marcher sur paris et
renverser la monarchie de juillet mais
l'opération tourne vite au désastre
les comploteurs sont arrêtés et la
famille bonaparte désavoue cette
tentative de coup d'état comme c'était
un individu turbulent qui a fréquenté la
charbonnerie qu organiser deux
tentatives de coup d'état le clan
bonaparte l'avait mis un peu à l'écart
et une réunion de famille un peu
drolatique où joseph chef de famille un
peu s'écoute en parler comme d'habitude
a essayé quand même de l'écarter au
bénéfice de son cousin fils de jérôme
bonaparte
c'est assez compliqué la ligne impériale
la reine hortense écrit à louis philippe
le suppliant de laisser son fils quitter
la france louis napoléon est alors
conduit à lorient est embarqué sur
landreau med le 21 novembre 1836
direction les états unis d'amérique où
il débarquera quatre mois plus tard
louis napoléon ne compte pas en rester
là il fait publier dix mille exemplaires
d'un violent pamphlet intitulé relation
historique des événements du 30 octobre
1836 dans lequel il fait l'apologie de
la démocratie bonapartiste définit comme
le gouvernement d'un sol par la volonté
de tous
les pressions de la france sur la suisse
le conduisent à s'installer en
angleterre où ils publient des idées
napoléonienne affirmant le prestige de
sa filiation et détaillant son programme
politique
l'important c'est que le gouvernement
quelle que soit sa forme s'occupe du
bonheur du peuple
profitant du mouvement de ferveur
bonapartiste suscité par le rapatriement
des cendres de l'empereur en france
louis napoléon débarque avec une poignée
de fidèles dans la nuit du 5 au 6 août
1840 près de boulogne-sur-mer l'esprit
embué par le rêve d'une seconde
tentative de coup d'état
cette dernière se soldent elle aussi par
un échec cuisant et louis napoléon est
condamné à l'emprisonnement à perpétuité
la forteresse de ham louis-philippe le
condamne à la prison à perpétuité au
fort de ham à côté d'amiens d'ailleurs
en sortant du tribunal le futur napoléon
iii regarde le président du tribunal dit
est-ce qu'on a déjà vu quelque chose de
perpétuels en france il bénéficie du
confort d'un appartement du droit de
correspondre avec l'extérieur et de
recevoir des visites
influencé par les idées de saint simon
qui voit en ce début d'industrialisation
un moteur du progrès social
il profite de sa captivité pour écrire
de l'extinction du paupérisme son cheval
de bataille sera dès lors la question du
mal être des ouvriers qui arrivent en
masse dans les villes pour travailler
dans les manufactures on peut pas dire
qu'il ait vraiment l'héritier des des
lumières parce que il a des idées qui
mêle aussi le modèle britannique
l'industrialisation le saint simonisme
il a toutes sortes de il a un cerveau
extrêmement effervescents et quelqu'un
qui dira de lui que son cerveau était
une gare end on sortait tout le temps
des lapins
donc c'est un personnage extrêmement
intellectuelle pas idéologue mais
inventif disons créatif le 25 mai 1846
il s'évade et se réfugier à londres va
s'évader du fort de ham
très discrètement en prenant les habits
d'un plâtrier après avoir fait deux
enfants à sa blanchisseuse bon il
s'évade et il se réfugie il parle par la
belgique il se réfugie en angleterre et
en angleterre il va tomber sous le
charme dans une telle ou telle soirée
mondaine puisque il était accueilli un
peu partout le on l'appelait victime
louis philippe et bien été accueillies
dans toutes les soirées dans une soirée
il va rencontrer miss howard harriet
howard qui est une femme ravissante
délicieuse qui est une demi-mondaine
tout de même il faut le savoir c'est
demi mondaine c'est à dire qu'elle se
donne un homme sur deux elle est
entretenue grassement et elle va
entretenir le futur napoléon iii il y
coule des jours heureux avec la belle
miss ariège
howard qui financera ses nombreuses
tentatives de retour en france
quand la révolution de 1848 fera germer
en lui un nouvel espoir
[Musique]
le pari de 1848 est encore celui de
l'ancien régime
les classes privilégiées ton de la laine
sur le dos du peuple
les épidémies la misère les conditions
d'hygiène la crise financière et
politique et toof les plus pauvres
chaque jour davantage le refus de
prendre en compte les aspirations
démocratiques attise la colère des
républicains et amène les ouvriers du
textile et du bâtiment
rejoints par les étudiants à manifester
la surrection tournant révolution après
la fusillade sanglante du boulevard des
capucines
le peuple de paris se soulève et prend
la capitale poussons louis philippe qui
refuse de tirer sur la foule a indiqué
en faveur de son petit fils le 25
février 1848 la deuxième république en
terre la monarchie de juillet et un
gouvernement provisoire se met en place
le 4 juin ont lieu les élections
complémentaires à l'assemblée
constituante chargée de rédiger et de
fautes et la constitution de la deuxième
république
à la surprise générale louis napoléon
qui séjournent encore à londres est élu
sur un programme de gauche dans quatre
départements la scène l'yonne la
charente inférieure et la corse
la ferveur populaire que suscite cette
élection conforte sa légitimité à
accéder au pouvoir
tandis qu'elle inquiète les autres
membres de l'assemblée
républicain monarchistes et socialistes
ne voit pas d'un bon oeil le retour de
cette poignée de bonapartiste sur les
marches du pouvoir
alphonse de lamartine hommes politiques
et célèbre dramaturge l'une des grandes
figures du romantisme en france tentent
de s'opposer à l'ascension fulgurante de
louis napoléon en proposant de remettre
au goût du jour la loi qui interdisait
aux membres de la famille bonaparte de
fouler le sol français
si cette proposition est refusé par
l'assemblée louis napoléon accusée
d'attiser le feu de la révolte se résout
à renoncer à son mandat ce qui
l'empêchera d'être mêlé au bain de sang
des journées de juin où le peuple de
paris protestera contre la fermeture des
ateliers nationaux censés fournir du
travail aux chômeurs parisien après la
révolution de février 1848 mais louis
napoléon est loin d'avoir abandonné ses
ambitions politiques
il se présente aux élections
législatives dans les quatre
départements déjà acquis ainsi qu'en
moselle élus dans les cinq départements
il rentre à paris où il va enfin pouvoir
siéger le 21 novembre 1848 l'assemblée
promulgué la constitution de la deuxième
république qui instaure pour la première
fois en france une véritable démocratie
mais louis napoléon de compte pas en
rester là
il est candidat à la première élection
présidentielle au suffrage universel
masculin
son plus sérieux adversaire et le
général conservateur louis eugène
cavaignac louis napoléon mène une
brillante campagne financée par sa douce
nice à rihad awards et obtient le
soutien de l'homme de lettres victor
hugo ainsi que celui du parti de l'ordre
composé de personnalités monarchiste
légitimiste comme adolphe thiers qui
deviendra le deuxième président de la
république française l'historien et
homme politique françois guizot odilon
barrot ou encore l'écrivain alexis de
tocqueville l'aria une phrase célèbre
d'adolphe thiers qui dit à propos de 9
de louis napoléon c'est un crétin que
l'on mènera et donc effectivement le
parti de l'ordre bien elle se sert du
nom de bonaparte
c'est très important à ce moment là il
n'y avait pas de campagne électorale
avec des affiches un peu partout mais il
suffisait que l'on prononce à le laisser
ces deux mots napoléon bonaparte pour
que évidemment ça rappelle des souvenirs
et des souvenirs glorieux alors que
quand on prononçait le nom de cavaignac
le nom de lamartine le nom de le de
ledru-rollin tous ceux qui qui se
présentait contre lui ça ne disait pas
grand chose dans les campagnes et comme
le parti de
andreu pense que c'est quelqu'un que
l'on pourra manipuler et on ne voit que
des avantages à soutenir la candidature
de louis napoléon à la présidence de la
république la première organisée au
suffrage universel suffrage universel un
peu restera mais quand même
et c'est à ce moment là que on découvre
que se crée ta que l'on mènera bien il a
quelques velléités à agir par lui même à
40 ans louis napoléon est élu premier
président de la république française et
après avoir prêté serment il prend ses
quartiers au palais de l'elysée
mais son amour anglaise miss howard ne
peut prétendre au titre de première dame
de france
c'est la princesse mathilde la cousine
et ex fiancée du président fille de
jérôme bonaparte qui remplira les
fonctions d'hôtesses de l'elysée c'est
un portrait de napoléon iii par cabanel
on veut dire qu'il se présente en chef
d'état et qu'il invente l'iconographie
des présidents de la république
n'oublions pas qu'il a été le premier
président de la république le pressent
de la seconde république mais et
qu'après lui tous les présidents se
feront représenter de cette façon
jusqu'à et y compris le président
pompidou
si la constitution restreint les
pouvoirs du président louis napoléon
affiche son illustre filiation en
adoptant les armoiries napoléonienne et
en se parant de l'uniforme de général en
chef de la garde nationale
il arbore le bicorne à plumes le grand
cordon et la légion d'honneur
après le refus de tiers audi lombard on
accepte de diriger le gouvernement
la situation politique reste instable
les rumeurs d'un coup d'état résonne
dans les couloirs et le ton monte entre
le gouvernement et les élus de
l'assemblée alors que se profilent les
élections législatives le gouvernement
français dont le très conservateur parti
de l'ordre détient une large majorité à
l'issue des élections s'inquiète de la
prise de pouvoir en italie de république
romaine dans le sillage de la vague
révolutionnaire de 1848 qui déferle sur
l'europe 7e république formée à rome
s'est donné pour mission d'anéantir les
états pontificaux et le pouvoir du pape
la france envoie donc un corps
expéditionnaire commandée par le général
ou dino lui ordonnant de mettre à terre
les troupes de garibaldi pour s'emparer
de rome et rétablir l'autorité du
souverain pontife en france le 13 juin
1849 la gauche républicaine menée par le
dru rollin réplique immédiatement
ce dernier tente une mise en accusation
du gouvernement auquel il reproche de
violer la constitution en déclarant la
guerre à l'italie s'en suit une
manifestation sur les grands boulevards
vite réprimés et qui force les élus
républicains à se réfugier au
conservatoire des arts et métiers où il
décide de former un gouvernement
provisoire
là encore ils sont mises en échec par le
gouvernement qui va prendre deux
terribles mesures de répression pour
museler l'extrême gauche
de nombreux journaux sont supprimés les
droits de la presse réduit à peau de
chagrin la liberté d'association régi
par une loi qui permet de la suspendre
et l'état de siège faciliter les députés
responsables de cette révolte étouffé
dans l'oeuf sont traduits en justice
pour complot et incitation à la guerre
civile
déchus de leur mandat est condamné par
contumace à la déportation
pourtant la popularité du président en
désaccord avec la majorité de
l'assemblée atteint des sommets
il entame une grande entreprise de
séduction parcourant la province
française au contact de ses citoyens
pendant que les foule acclame
il se démarque du parti de l'ordre sur
la question romaine il soutient les
républicains italien dans leur lutte
ce qui lui vaut l'appui de la gauche
mais aussi l'inimitié du gouvernement
conservateur et la démission d'odilon
barreaux le président ouvre les
hostilités en critiquant ouvertement
l'assemblée qui détient le si grand
pouvoir de voter les lois en déclarant
mes amis les plus sincères les plus
dévoués ne sont pas dans les palais ils
sont sous le choc ils ne sont pas sous
les lambris dorés
ils sont dans les ateliers et dans les
campagnes
un nouveau gouvernement se met en place
formé de proches dévouée au président
est dirigée par le général d'hôtes poule
un vétéran des guerres napoléoniennes
la bresse bonapartiste milite quant à
elle pour une prolongation du mandat
présidentiel
la loi falloux promulguée le 15 mars
1850 réglemente l'instruction publique
et accorde la liberté d'enseignement la
fin du mandat présidentiel approche à
grands pas louis napoléon c'est que le
temps presse il lui faut obtenir une
révision de la constitution qui
autoriserait un second mandat mais
toutes ces tentatives échouent et le
parfum d'une rumeur de coup d'état
embaume les couloirs de l'assemblée qui
craint déjà le rétablissement de lempire
on l'a fait élire président de la
république mais la constitution qui est
une constitution très mal rédigé cette
constitution de 1848 est belle ne lui
reconnaît aucun droit à re election il
ne peut pas eu peut-être redevenir
député mais c'est pas grand chose donc
il est prisonnier de tous les côtés pis
s'aperçoit que toute idée qu'il peut
avoir est rejetée et puis il ya une
histoire aussi c'est sordide de gros
sous c'est à dire que l'assemblée lui
refuse une dotation descente en secret
la garde rapprochée de louis napoléon se
regroupent autour d'un obscur personnage
le duc de morny quelques années plus tôt
louis napoléon faisait la rencontre de
charles auguste de morny qui se présente
alors comme son demi frère
il est le fruit des amours passionnées
de la reine hortense de boire nez avec
le compte de flahaut un fidèle de
napoléon 1er
hortense de bornes et personnalité très
forte par ailleurs a eu un enfant
adultérin avec l'officier flahaut qui
était lui-même bâtard de talleyrand
c'est une histoire extrêmement
romantique et ce demi frère adultérin de
louis napoléon et bien il ne l'a
découvert que après la mort de sa mère
demi-frère qui ne sera d'ailleurs jamais
officiellement reconnu en tant que tel
mais qui est un homme de très grande
influence et un homme dont on peut dire
qu'il et affairiste c'est un personnage
prodigieusement intelligent et napoléon
sa rencontre
il l'appelle et lui dit écoute j'ai
besoin de toi pour faire une nouvelle
tentative de coup d'état j'ai déjà
échoué à strasbourg j'ai déjà échoué
échoué à boulogne parce qu'on s'y est
mal pris mais avec toi ça marchera c'est
le duc de morny devenu l'homme de
confiance du président qui sera chargé
de mettre sur pied la bien nommée
opération rubicon
comme césar avant lui avait traversé le
fleuve pour braver la loi du sénat
romain louis napoléon se jette dans
l'expérience risque et de fomenter un
coup d'état
il fixe symboliquement la date au 2
décembre 1851 jour anniversaire du sacre
de son illustre modèle napoléon 1er
dans la nuit du 1er au 2 décembre
les troupes du général de saint-arnaud
fonde sur la capitale paralysant les
imprimeries et procédant à l'arrestation
des opposants au président pour éviter
tout mouvement de résistance
adolphe thiers et changarnier bras armé
de l'assemblée sont tirés de leur
sommeil par des officiers de cavalerie
pendant que louis napoléon fait
placardées sur les murs de paris
son appel au peuple ainsi qu'une
proclamation destiné à l'armée il y
déclare l'état de siège
la dissolution de l'assemblée nationale
abroge la loi du 31 mai 1850 qui
restreignait le corps électoral et
annonce son intention de rédiger une
nouvelle constitution
les députés tentent de résister et
d'appeler le peuple à se soulever victor
hugo harangue la foule des quartiers
populaires mais toute tentative est
violemment réprimé
dans la nuit du 4 décembre les soldats
ouvrent le feu sur la foule provoquant
un véritable bain de sang sur les grands
boulevards les semaines qui suivent sont
marqués du sceau des dénonciations
calomnieuses arrestations massives et
exécutions sommaires les républicains
deviennent les nouveaux ennemis à
abattre les journaux qui sont
défavorables à louis napoléon sont
interdits et la peur s'installe en même
temps qu'une terrible répression on
envoie les prisonniers politiques et les
traîtres en algérie ou bagne de cayenne
victor hugo fuite en belgique début
dents longues exil qui durera vingt ans
mais louis napoléon craignant d'être
pris pour un tyran adoucit sa politique
et prend des mesures de grâce
présentant le coup d'état comme un mal
nécessaire et préventif contre le
pouvoir autoritaire grandissant de
l'assemblée les 20 et 21 décembre
les français sont invités à se prononcer
par plébiscite sur les réformes du
prince-président avec une majorité
écrasante le peuple approuve le coup
d'état et aspirant à la paix place de
grands espoirs en la personne de louis
napoléon
pour accomplir son destin il lui reste à
achever la deuxième république pour
établir lempire ouvrant ainsi la voie à
l'écriture de sa légende noire alimentée
entre autres par victor hugo dans son
histoire d'un crime
louis napoléon souhaite établir un état
centralisé à l'exécutif fort
d'inspiration républicaine et s'appuyant
sur l'approbation du peuple par le biais
de plébiscite
il affirme ainsi poursuivre l'oeuvre de
son illustre aïeul napoléon 1er tout en
développant une vraie politique sociale
le 14 janvier 1852 la nouvelle
constitution est promulguée elle confie
pour dix ans le pouvoir exécutif au
président de la république élu au
suffrage universel direct
il peut nommer et révoquer les membres
du gouvernement à sa convenance
reste le seul apte à déclarer la guerre
et à conclure des traités relatifs à la
paix ou commerce
cependant il hésite encore à rétablir
lempire et pour s'assurer du soutien
inextinguible de son peuple
entame une grande tournée des provinces
françaises partout il est acclamé aux
cris de vive le louis napoléon vive
l'empereur et le 9 octobre 1852 il tient
ce discours à bordeaux certaines
personnes disent lempire c'est la guerre
moi je dis lempire c'est la paix c'est
la paix car la france le désir
la gloire ce legs bien à titre
d'héritage mais non la guerre j'en
conviens cependant j'ai comme l'empereur
bien des conquêtes à faire je veux comme
lui conquérir à la conciliation les
parties dissidents et ramené dans le
courant du grand fleuve populaire des
dérivations hostile qui vont se perdre
sans profit pour personne nous avons
d'immenses territoires un culte à
défricher des routes à ouvrir des ports
a creusé des rivières à rendre navigable
des canaux à terminer notre réseau de
chemin de fer à compléter nous avons en
face de marseille un vaste royaume
assimilé à la france nous avons enfin
partout des ruines a relevé de faux
dieux à abattre des vérités à faire
triompher
voilà comment je comprends lempire si l'
empire doit se rétablir
[Musique]
le 7 novembre 1852 le sénat propose de
rétablir le régime impérial héréditaire
approuvé par plébiscite le 2 décembre
louis napoléon bonaparte devient
officiellement napoléon iii empereur des
français il va employer toutes ses
forces à relancer la croissance
économique
moderniser les infrastructures et
améliorer la qualité de vie des ouvriers
[Musique]
c'est lors d'une réception fastueuse
donner aux tuileries que louis napoléon
déclare sa flamme à la belle et
virginale eugénie de mon tir haut une
jeune comtesse espagnol il va lui faire
une cour effrénée mais au génie sachant
bien quel point ce napoléon bonaparte
est un coureur de jupons ne voulait pas
succomber comme ça dans un premier temps
très hâtivement
elle lui a dit mais je ne serai pas
votre votre montespan je ne serai pas
votre lavallière est en effet un soir
par exemple à compiègne il aborde la
belle au génie et philippe par où passe
le chemin de votre chambre par la
chapelle elle cyr et il a finit par
l'épouser naturellement bien que tout le
monde contester ce mariage le vieux
jérôme disait mais bon il l'épousera
beats qu'il va épouser la première qui
va se refuser à lui le la princesse
mathilde disait mais il va l'épouser
mais ça va être un mariage
lamentable puisqu'elle n'a pas plus de
coeur que de cul ces deux portraits sont
la reprise en tapisserie des portraits
officiels et exécuté par littérale terre
au moment du mariage de napoléon iii et
de génie de mentir aux ce2 portraits ont
été diffusés très largement copié en de
nombreux exemplaires pour représenter
les souverains aussi bien dans les
préfectures que dans
les mairies sur le modèle de londres
napoléon iii veut faire de paris une
capitale moderne débarrassé de sa
réputation d'insalubrité et de
surpopulation
il imagine avec le baron haussmann une
ville nouvelle percée de grands
boulevards dax de communication reliant
les grandes gares un modèle architecture
découpé en vingt arrondissements où tous
les citoyens trouveront leur place
l'empereur napoléon iii a de grands
projets pour la capitale dont il
souhaite faire une ville à rayonnement
universel une ville moderne et le baron
haussmann va carrément redessiné paris
la ville à laquelle il donne la
physionomie que nous connaissons en
traçant les grandes artères les grandes
avenues rue de rivoli avenue de l'opéra
tout le nouveau quartier en fête de
l'opéra va faire ouvrir et créer l'opéra
l'opéra garnier contre génie pose la
question d'ailleurs à garnier 10 mai 7
quel style c'est du style napoléon iii à
gesté répond dernier évidemment il y
avait dans son intention certainement le
fait d'embellir la capitale mais aussi
il se disait que en cas d'émeutes comme
il y en avait eu à la révolution de 48
sous louis philippe est bien dans les
grandes artères
on pouvait quand même maîtrisé la foule
beaucoup plus facilement que dans toutes
les petites ruelles
ainsi louis napoléon est il à l'origine
des premiers logements sociaux et de la
construction de cités ouvrières
il encourage la création de square pour
les enfants des ouvriers du parc des
buttes chaumont et montsouris des bois
de vincennes et de boulogne pendant la
période même du renne tout ça est lancé
un rythme fou il ya énormément
d'expropriation etc
paris est donc un chantier et c'est
après après la guerre de 70 dans les
années 1880 puis après et a fortiori
1900 que les parisiens toucheront en
quelque sorte les dividendes du second
empire avec leurs très belles avenues en
1854 à la suite de la déclaration de
guerre entre la russie et l'empiré
ottoman la france s'engage aux côtés de
l'angleterre et s'allier au turc dans la
guerre de crimée qui durera jusqu'en
1856 cet engagement permet à napoléon
iii de rétablir le prestige de la france
sur la scène européenne
en obtenant la capitulation de la russie
après la destruction de sa flotte à
sébastopol et la bataille de malakoff
à paris les grands travaux continuent et
la capitale accueille dès 1855
l'exposition universelle qui témoigne de
l'intérêt de l'empereur pour les progrès
techniques
c'est aussi l'émergence des grand
magasin le bon marché le printemps la
samaritaine de nouveaux édifices publics
comme l'hôtel dieu où le théâtre du
châtelet
napoléon iii s'attelle à la construction
du réseau ferroviaire français
l'état s'engage financièrement
contribuant au développement
d'entreprises sidérurgiques et de
travaux publics afin de réaliser des
milliers de kilomètres de voies ferrées
qui desserviront en 1870 toutes les
moyennes et grandes villes du pays
il lance un gigantesque chantier de
construction du réseau routier puis de
développement des voies navigables avec
la création de canaux et de grandes
compagnies maritimes messageries
maritimes compagnie générale
transatlantique
parallèlement louis napoléon veut
réformer le système bancaire pour
favoriser l'essor industriel
c'est l'âge d'or des élites
administratives des hommes d'affaires et
des banquiers
il crée des banques de dépôt et favorise
le crédit foncier
c'est la naissance du crédit foncier de
france pour le monde agricole du crédit
immobilier pour financer les sociétés
industrielles ou encore du crédit
lyonnais
l'empereur napoléon iii met fin au
protectionnisme économique en négociant
secrètement un traité commercial avec
l'angleterre abolissant notamment les
droits de douane sur les matières
premières les produits alimentaires
textile et métallurgique cette mesure
d'abord impopulaire auprès des
industriels français permet la
modernisation des modes de production
napoléon iii est l homme qui savait
quand même prendre des décisions et si
on compare à la période précédente qui
était à l'époque de la monarchie de
juillet on s'aperçoit que la monarchie
de juillet avaient tous les tous les
atouts pour faire une grande un grand
pays industriel sur le modèle de
l'angleterre
eh bien elle ne l'a pas fait parce que y
avait toujours un petit retard à la
décision il y avait toujours des
changements de gouvernement y avait une
indécision tout au long de la monarchie
de juillet dans cette période absolument
clé du 19e siècle et bien quand arrive
le second empire
malgré tout les côtés autoritaire le
côté répressif pendant longtemps
au début tout au moins
du second empire qu'il doit s'affirmer
avec quand même une apparence de
dictature et bien des décisions sont
prises qui ont très heureux effet sur le
plan économique
dès 1856 débutent les fameuses séries au
château de compiègne où semble encore
résonner l'air défait du rhin
d'offenbach ou de l'hymne à napoléon iii
et à son vaillant peuple composé par
rossini à l'occasion de la seconde
exposition universelle la cotonne grosso
modo entre octobre et décembre et bien
napoléon iii et eugénie vont prendre
l'habitude de lancer des invitations à
des séries d'invités dont le nombre
varié oscillé entre 60 et une centaine
d'invités rassemblés en même temps pour
une durée de sept à huit jours
consécutifs
ici à compiègne
un train spécial est affrétés pour
conduire des invités triés sur le volet
l'architecte garnier les peintres de la
croix ou dorées les écrivains flaubert
d'humains ou encore des savants comme
louis pasteur
on va inviter des hommes de lettres on
va inviter des savants va inviter des
artistes mais principalement il faut
quand même pas se cacher que c'est
presque majoritairement la cour
l'entourage des souverains les membres
de la maison de l'empereur et de
l'impératrice qui sont les plus nombreux
autour de la seule obligation qui est
faite aux invités des séries c'est de
dîner le soir en habit à la table de
l'empereur sans quoi dans la journée
tout le monde est libre de faire ce
qu'il lui plaît
l'hospitalité de rigueur et l'éthique
est réduite à sa plus simple expression
on pratique la chasse les promenades en
forêt eugène viollet le duc dirige la
visite des travaux du château de
pierrefonds commandité par l'empereur
les tableaux vivants charades et
parodies constituent les divertissements
à la mode
les souverains les cours plus anciennes
regardez un peu avec hauteur ce qui se
passait à paris et bien napoléon iii et
eugénie au ébloui l'europe par le luxe
et la beauté des fêtes et des réceptions
qui se déroulait à paris pour toutes ces
grandes occasions il est très soucieux
de développer aussi le les industries du
luxe de développer des stations
thermales c'est notamment l'âge d'or de
biarritz biarritz où l'on construit une
immense villa pour la princesse eugénie
qui deviendra plus tard l'hôtel du
palais tout ça donne au second empire
une ambiance à peu près extrêmement
luxueuse et en même temps sulfureuse
parce qu'évidemment tout le monde n'en
profite pas le 14 janvier 1858 napoléon
iii et son épouse seront à l'opéra de la
rue le peletier quand une énorme
détonation souffle les vitrines des
magasins et projettent leur carrosse à
plusieurs mètres
le couple impérial est sain et sauf mais
cet attentat perpétré par orsini fera
près de 150 blessés
si les arts et les lettres sont soumis à
la censure napoléon iii mise sur les
avancées scientifiques et techniques en
soutenant les travaux de louis pasteur
et en appuyant le projet de ferdinand de
lesseps de percer le canal de suez qui
sera inaugurée le 17 novembre 1869
l'empereur des français promet à victor
emmanuel ii roi de piémont-sardaigne de
lui prêter main forte dans son combat
vers l'unité de l'italie en échange de
la savoie et de nice le conflit se noue
entre l' empire austro-hongrois de
françois joseph et la coalition franco
sarde précipitant les deux camps dans la
campagne d'italie de 1859 qui se solde
par une victoire de napoléon iii lors de
la bataille de solferino
[Applaudissements]
après son succès en italie napoléon iii
profit de la guerre de sécession
américaine pour se lancer dans une
expédition au mexique afin de créer un
empire latin catholique et d'explorer de
nouveaux débouchés économiques pour
resserrer l'alliance franco autrichienne
mise à mal au cours de la guerre
d'italie napoléon iii propose la
couronne du mexique au frère de françois
joseph maximilien de habsbourg
mais en 1865 la guerre de sécession
prend fin et le gouvernement américain
soutient les troupes rebelles obligeant
napoléon iii a abandonné le mexique
maximilien qui refusent d'abdiquer est
exécutée et le rapprochement avec
françois joseph définitivement compromis
à partir de 1860 de l'empereur se montre
plus audacieux dans sa politique sociale
il fonde la société du prince impérial
qui prêtent de l'argent aux ouvriers il
reconnaît le droit de grève
puis les syndicats créé le premier
système de retraite et une caisse
d'assurance contre les accidents du
travail
victor duruy son ministre de
l'instruction publique prônent un
enseignement primaire gratuit
obligatoire et ouvre l'enseignement
secondaire aux filles il réintègre
l'histoire la géographie la philosophie
les langues vivantes
le dessin la gymnastique et la musique
dans les programmes scolaires
[Musique]
le 21 juin 1870 le prince
franco-allemand léopold ii and holler
nothing beringen se voit proposer le
trône d'espagne vacant depuis deux ans
mais la france s'y oppose farouchement
et demande au roi de prusse par
l'intermédiaire de son ambassadeur
benedetti la confirmation écrite du
retrait de léopold bismarck alors
chancelier de prusse rédige le
télégramme en résumant les propos de son
roi leur donnant volontairement une
tournure provocatrice suggérant que
l'ambassadeur français a été congédié de
manière humiliante bismarck veut faire
l'unification de l'allemagne et il sait
que cette unification du nord reçu de
tous les petits royaumes allemand
unification qui ne s'était pas faite
contre napoléon par exemple avec la
prusse mais la prusse seul tandis que la
bismarckien l'occasion avec en faisant
la guerre aux français de réveiller un
esprit de conquête celle et les
allemands aussitôt la presse parisienne
crient au scandale
excitant les velléités belliqueuses du
peuple et des parlementaires tiers
voyant le ton monte dangereusement
tentent d'arrêter la manoeuvre il sait
que l'armée française est vieillissante
et mal préparée
le 19 juillet la france déclare la
guerre à la prusse la machine infernale
est en marche
napoléon iii et son chef du gouvernement
emile ollivier se laisse entraîner par
les partisans de la guerre dont
l'impératrice eugénie
alors que les états allemands affichent
leur soutien la prusse île napoléon iii
ne voulait pas cette guerre de 70 et 7 e
génie qui s'est cabré en lui disant si
on ne la fait pas à cause de toi
l'empiré déshonorait on se lance dans la
guerre on déclare la guerre alors que
rien n'est prêt que
il n'ya pas stratégies militaires
arrêtés napoléon monte au front et
s'aperçoit que les soldats cherchent
leurs officiers que les officiels
chercheurs soldats que l'armée dans une
débandade totale et lui napoléon et dans
la débandade la plus complète aussi
pourquoi parce que il souffre mille
morts
quand on sait qu'il avait dans la vessie
un calcul qui mesurait 5 cm sur 4 il a
été pathétique on a souvent dit
d'ailleurs qu'il était plutôt suicidaire
il essaie de se faire tuer par un cette
guerre ça a été affreux de bout en bout
les soldats de l'armée prussienne sont
plus nombreux et mieux s'organiser
très vite pour les français la guerre
tourne au cauchemar
napoléon iii déambulent malades sur le
champ de bataille pendant qu'à paris
l'impératrice assure la régence
finalement le 2 septembre 1870 les
troupes de napoléon iii sont encerclés à
sedan et au terme de la bataille 83
mille soldats français dont l'empereur
sont faits prisonniers
à paris les républicains demandent la
déchéance de lempire et la foule prend
d'assaut le palais bourbon
eugénie se réfugie chez le docteur evans
un américain qui organise sa fuite vers
l'angleterre
pendant ce temps à l'hôtel de ville léon
gambetta jules favre et jules-ferry
proclame la république et constituent un
gouvernement provisoire de défense
nationale qui ordonne au peuple français
de résister contre l'armée prussienne
que toutes les communes solev que toutes
les campagnes prennent feu que toutes
les forêts s'emplissent de voix tonnante
que de chaque maison ils sortent un
soldat que le faubourg deviennent
régiment que la ville se fasse armés
les prussiens sont 800 milles vous êtes
40 millions d'hommes dressez vous
essouffler sur eux rouler des rochers
entassés des pavés changer les sauts
caen hb changer les sillons en fosse
combattez avec tout ce qui vous tombe
sous la main prenez les pierres de notre
terre sacrée lapider les envahisseurs
avec les ossements de notre mère la
france aux citoyens dans les cailloux du
chemin ce que vous leur jeter à la face
c'est la patrie extrait de l'appel à la
résistance lancé en 1871 contre l'armée
prussienne par victory cours
durant plus de quatre mois une épreuve
terrible attend les parisiens à siéger
dans la capitale par les prussiens
les provisions viennent vite à manquer
il ne reste que les rats et les chevaux
de la cavalerie à se mettre sous la dent
même les animaux du zoo de vincennes se
retrouve sur les tables des restaurants
le 18 janvier 1871
guillaume premier est proclamé empereur
allemand dans la galerie des glaces du
château de versailles le traité de
francfort signé le 10 mai met
officiellement fin à la guerre oblige la
france a cédé l'alsace lorraine et à
payer une indemnité de guerre s'élevant
à 5 milliards de francs or le peuple
français se sont humiliés alors quand
hier veut désarmer paris après avoir
signé l'armistice avec bismarck est mis
en place son gouvernement un nouveau
soulèvement groupe
la commune de paris durera deux mois et
s'achèvera dans un bain de sang avant
qu'à dole food hier de devienne le
premier président de la iiième
république française
[Musique]
et
il
le 19 mars 1871 bismarck a mis fin à la
captivité de napoléon iii qui a rejoint
son épouse et son fils atcha seul first
en angleterre là il écrit de nombreux
ouvrages rêvant encore d'un retour
triomphal à l'image de celui de l'île
d'elbe par son aïeul
mais il succombe à une opération le 9
janvier 1873
eugénie perdra aussi son fils le prince
impérial
engagé volontaire dans l'armée
britannique en afrique du sud et tué à
23 ans par les zoulous
pour les anglais c'est vraiment
l'incarnation du jeune héros qui meurt
en brave et alors que les français au
presque totalement oublié ce jeune
prince dont on ne connaît guère que sa
mort ce n'est qu'en 1920 au terme d'une
très longue vie qu'elle les rejoindra
dans le mausolée qu'elle avait fait
construire au sud de l'angleterre à
farnborough où la famille impériale
repose aujourd'hui encore
[Musique]
napoléon iii a gouverné pendant 18 ans
et passent presque inaperçus dans
l'histoire de france qui l'a pourtant
fortement marqué de son empreinte et
dont on conserve aujourd'hui encore un
héritage ray m décrié par les écrivains
de son temps qui ont laissé de lui
l'image d'un prince président abe cl ou
d'un empereur autoritaire il est toute
une facette du personnage qui reste
difficile à éclairer temps les
projecteurs de l'histoire ont greffé sur
lui la peau d'un autre fantasme et
napoléon iii il a été longtemps détesté
par ce qui est il a eu un adversaire
redoutable sur le plan était requis
était victor hugo qui a écrit les
châtiments et ça a été la condamnation
pendant très longtemps puis la troisième
république s'est bâti un peu sur la
critique du second empire
s'il n'a pas construit comme son oncle
illustre sa propre légende
s'il sait peut-être et forcés d'entrer
dans un costume trop grand pour lui
il a pourtant su transformer durablement
la société française dont il reste le
tout dernier monarque sans doute le plus
mal connu
[Musique]